The peer review process for journal publication
is essentially a quality control mechanism.
It is a process by which experts evaluate
scholarly works, and its objective is to
ensure a high quality of published science.
However, peer reviewers do not make the
decision to accept or reject papers. At most, they
recommend a decision. At peer-reviewed journals,
decision-making authority rests solely with
journal editors or the journal’s editorial board.
Indeed, it is the journal editor who is considered
to be central to the decision making process.
Typically, after a paper is submitted
to a journal, a journal editor screens
the manuscript and decides whether or
not to send it for full peer review.
Only after clearing the initial screening is the
manuscript sent to one or more peer reviewers.
Finally, journal editors or the journal’s
editorial board consider the peer reviewers’
reports and make the final decision to accept
or reject the manuscript for publication.
Approximately 3 million manuscripts are submitted
to journals every year. Given the large volume of
manuscript submissions, more and more journals
follow a policy of screening papers before
sending them for full peer review. Journal editors
typically look at hundreds of manuscripts a year.
One of the first items that editors will look at
is the cover letter, and they may not get further
than the cover letter if the study does not seem
interesting enough. Therefore, it is imperative
that authors craft a well-written cover letter
that highlights the significance and strength of
their research as well as provides a good reason
why the manuscript is a good fit for the journal.
Editors will then go through the abstract
and may even skim through the introduction,
figures and tables, or other sections of the paper
to determine whether the manuscript passes their
quality threshold. During the initial screening,
journal editors mainly check the following :
Does the manuscript fit the journal’s scope and
aim, and will it be of interest to the readership?
Is the manuscript of minimum acceptable
quality? Is the content and writing good
enough to make it worth reviewing?
and, Is the manuscript compliant
with the journal’s instructions for authors?
If the manuscript clearly lies outside the
scope of the journal, then a rapid rejection
allows the author to quickly find and submit
their manuscript to another journal. Peer
reviewers’ time is wasted when they have
to spend time evaluating and giving feedback
for a manuscript of clearly inferior quality.
Once a manuscript clears the initial
screening, it is sent for peer review.
There are three common types of peer
review for journal publication :
First, single blind, where the names of
reviewers are not revealed to authors. .
Second, Double blind, where the names of reviewers
and authors are not revealed to each other .
and Third, Open peer review,
where the Names of authors and
reviewers are revealed to each other .
Generally, a minimum of 2 or up to 6 peer
reviewers are chosen for the peer review. Peer
reviewers are ideally experts in their field.
Journals usually build a pool of peer reviewers
that have a good track record of producing
high-quality reviews. Or they may scan the
bibliography to identify potential reviewers
or contact researchers they met at conferences and
seminars. Many journals will first ask potential
reviewers whether they are willing to review the
manuscript before assigning them as reviewers.
Editors have to be careful to select
reviewers who have sufficient subject
matter expertise to do justice to the manuscript.
Therefore, highly technical papers or papers from
niche subject areas may take longer to review,
because it may take editors some time
to locate appropriate reviewers.
Some journals give authors the option of
recommending preferred and non-preferred
reviewers. Authors would do well to take
advantage of this option if available
as it can expedite the review process, since it
saves the journal time in looking for reviewers.
The peer review is completed once
all the reviewers send the journal
a detailed report with their comments on
the manuscript and their recommendation.
Typically, journals ask reviewers to
complete their reviews within 3-4 weeks.
However, few journals have a
mechanism to enforce the deadline,
which is why it can be hard to predict how
long the peer review process will take.
The journal editor or editorial board considers
the feedback provided by the peer reviewers
and arrives at a decision. The following are
the most common decisions that are made :
First, accept without any changes . The journal
will publish the paper in its original form .
Second, accept with minor revisions .
The journal will publish the paper and
asks the author to make small corrections .
Third, accept after major revisions . The
journal will publish the paper provided
the authors make the changes suggested
by the reviewers and editors .
Fourth, revise and resubmit . The
journal is willing to reconsider the
paper in another round of decision
making after the authors make major changes .
And fifth, reject the paper . The journal
will not publish the paper or reconsider it
even if the authors make major revisions .
The first option, accept without any
changes, is rare. The second decision,
accept with minor revisions, is typically the
best outcome authors should hope for. Once a
journal rejects a paper outright, authors are
well advised not to resubmit to the same journal.
If the journal wanted to reconsider the paper,
they would have issued a conditional rejection.
An outright rejection means that
the journal thinks the paper will
not meet its publication standards or
interests even after heavy revisions.
Editors’ decision-making policies vary.
Some reject when even one peer
reviewer recommends rejection,
some when the majority recommend rejection, and
some only when all reviewers recommend rejection.
It is common for peer reviewers to give
conflicting feedback on the same manuscript.
One journal editorial went as far as to
say “Unanimity between reviewers is rare.”
In cases of conflicting feedback,
the journal editor may choose to
send the paper to a third reviewer
before arriving at a decision,
and the author may have to wait longer for
the peer review process to be completed.
In summary, Because of a
large number of submissions,
top-tier journals are often forced to reject even
high quality manuscripts for various reasons,
like a large number of submissions or lack
of fit with the journal’s editorial focus.
While reviewers and editors easily agree on
what is clearly not acceptable for publication,
deciding what is worthy of
publication is a tougher challenge.
Finally, journal editors make decisions
to accept or reject papers based on their
opinion of the papers’ publication
worthiness and reviewers’ comments.